now international talks on iran's
nuclear programme have resumed after a
five-month hiatus the meetings in vienna
include representatives from china
germany france britain and russia the
talks are meant to bring iran back into
compliance with a deal it signed in 2015
that's supposed to ensure it doesn't
acquire a nuclear weapon and the u.s
abandoned that deal three years later
under the trump administration iran then
went on to step up its enrichment of
uranium and limited access and limited
access to international inspectors but
now the parties are trying to update the
agreement with the us participating
indirectly
executive vice president of the
institute for peace and diplomacy in
toronto canada we asked him earlier what
chance of success these negotiations
have
i don't think it's the last chance in
complex negotiations like these can take
a while and this was the case even with
the previous or initial agreement
known as the joint comprehensive plan of
action and look today was just the first
day of negotiations and it's just too
early to make an assessment whether
it's this is go there's going to be a
deal reached or not but i see positive
signs and signals coming out of vienna
and this makes me optimistic about the
prospect of iran nuclear talks and let
me tell you why i am optimistic today
more than i was weeks ago before the
negotiations restarted first iran has
agreed to continue the negotiations
where they were left off with the
previous administration this means that
there's not going to be more time spent
nor dedicated on renegotiating what was
already negotiated negotiated with the
previous government and it means that
now there is a foundation up in which
that more issues could be discussed and
potentially resolved by other parties to
the nuclear deal and another positive
development is the fact that two working
groups one specifically on sanction
relief and another one on
iran's nuclear activities will be
restarting their work in order to breach
the gap between the demands and
expectations between tehran and
washington